the yield of 15,000 acres
of wheat in a single cargo
the yield of arming of machine
during the first world war we
started bringing these machines
out of the wheat field and we fed the world
they drown like restin of that sometime
please them coming the cargoes of wheat
the farmers themselves have
been drowned by this abundant
to save themselves our farmers of developed
a nationwide system of granaries to star the
surface of an important property
their wheat their corn that
it was the only way we could relieve their
markets the only way that it carry on it is
called the ever normal battery of vast reserve
which now gives us tremendous things or in the
disruptive way we think is a cycle as the
weapon for our defense here is the every
normal battery of the Corn Belt in every Township
in every County then like these filled with cars
abundant in the mountain
abundance on the range
we have everything we often have
everything we need we have the open
strength we have the hidden strengths
we are going to increase this place not
for today not for tomorrow but
for the century of the nation